this episode is brought to you by
audible check out audible's limited time
holiday special by following the link
below
[Music]
we're gonna try something new in this
episode i talk a lot about the problems
of capitalism and the challenges we face
as important as that kind of analysis is
it can make socialists like me come off
as very negative people
so in this video i'm going to talk about
what makes socialism a positive
worldview
and suggests that you might already be a
socialist and just not know it yet
before we begin let me ask one small
favor of you the viewer
if you're watching this in the us
there's a very high likelihood that you
have a negative opinion of the word
socialism
that's okay if you want to go ahead and
leave a thumbs down on this video that's
perfectly fine
i would just ask that you stick around
till the end you might change your mind
and even if you don't you'll at least
have a better understanding of what
socialism actually means than if you
just hear the term misused on tv
i'll include a bunch of resources and
further reading in the description if
you're interested in learning more
as one final disclaimer to my friends on
the left i'm using the term socialism
very broadly here
as a sort of catch-all for generally
leftist thought this episode is more for
the people who are interested in
learning what distinguishes the left
from typical american capitalist
perspectives
so with all that in mind let's get
started i think we should start with the
distinction between liberals and the
left
this is something that trips up a lot of
people and it doesn't help that the
media seems to use the two terms
interchangeably
let's start with what the two camps have
in common both leftists
and liberals care about democratic
governance and believe in universal
human rights
but liberals contrary to what many
conservative news figures will tell you
still put their faith in capitalist
market-based economics they believe that
the problems in our capitalist society
stem from corrupt individuals
and if we simply root out these bad
actors and pursue incremental reform the
system can function properly
leftists have a different perspective
they believe that the problems we face
are inherent to capitalism and that the
system is functioning exactly how it's
supposed to
the left sees the problems identified by
liberals not as problems within
capitalism
but as a byproduct of a properly
functioning capitalist machine
capitalism cannot solve the problems it
creates because that would impede growth
so leftists believe that we need to move
beyond capitalism in favor of a better
system
one of the most important distinctions
to make between liberals and the left is
that the left is concerned primarily
with materialism
that is the material realities of
people's lives let's take an example
policy proposal
student debt cancellation for a liberal
cancelling even a thousand dollars of
debt would be a huge symbolic victory
for a socialist the amount canceled and
the total amount of indebtedness are
less important than most people's more
immediate concern
being able to pay the installment every
month the material reality for most
students is the challenge of affording
the monthly payment
if that challenge is not addressed then
the policy does not materially improve
that person's life
and is therefore insufficient let's take
another example
medicare for all this is a big one for
the left because making healthcare free
at the point of service would have an
immediate and enormous material impact
on the average person's life
if you can afford to go to the doctor
you could literally be extending your
life by having access to the medicine
you need
for liberals they'd be happy with a
program that kind of covers some people
but only under certain circumstances and
private healthcare has to stay of course
and then when they pass that bill they
consider it a huge victory
same with race relations the liberals
are content to kneel in traditional
african garb and paint black lives
matter over a street
but they fail to address any of the
actual material concerns of the black
lives matter movement
that's the difference symbolic victories
versus actual material change
to the left the most important thing is
materially improving the lives of normal
people
okay now you should have a better
understanding of the whole left versus
liberal thing
but just to refresh liberals may
genuinely care about people but their
policies do not adequately improve
people's lives
they still want to operate under the
capitalist system and therefore are not
part of the left
let's take a minute to consider which of
these worldviews is more appealing to
you
i'd wager that most people are more
concerned with their material realities
than winning empty symbolic victories
you want to see tangible benefits to
your own life and the lives of your
neighbors
people have economic concerns and they
need to be addressed
we inherently understand this that we
need to look out for ourselves and each
other
and that's a key pillar of socialism i
think there's a lot to be said for
things we inherently understand
if you were to ask a seven-year-old what
we should do about people who don't have
a place to live or enough food to eat or
the medicine they need to live
what do you think they'd say they'd say
we should give those people what they
need
humans are a social and altruistic
species we all start out with these
morals and then we're slowly
indoctrinated into capitalism as we grow
and it's not like we couldn't afford
more humanitarian policies
it would just mean corporations wouldn't
make as much money and that's a deal
breaker under capitalism
another key part of socialist ideology
is democracy
is about as american as apple pie we're
always talking about how we have a
strong democracy how democracy is what
makes our country great
and yet our elected officials both
democrats and republicans
fight tooth and nail against expanding
democracy they're constantly making it
harder to vote
or giving corporations more power over
their workers or refusing to acknowledge
the rights of certain groups
socialists want to expand democracy we
believe in the ability of the people to
make decisions for themselves
we should be able to elect our officials
directly not let other people choose
them for us
our elections are unnecessarily complex
the electoral college is a silly system
and politics has become little more than
a sporting event socialists want to give
electoral power back to the people so we
can
directly vote for policies that would
improve the lives of average people
not continue to enrich the already
obscenely wealthy and powerful
we should have a say in how our
workplaces are run not be beholden to
every counterproductive corporate
initiative
if you've ever worked in retail you know
just how badly the stores are managed
take best buy for example i used to work
at best buy as a camera expert
my job description was to help people
find the best camera to suit their needs
i was good at it i love cameras and i
know how to pick the best one for any
application
but like any retail environment the
managers would swoop in
tell us how to do our jobs and we'd end
up with unhappy customers or feel
horrible about ourselves for pressuring
people to sign up for credit cards they
don't need
workers aren't stupid we know how to run
our departments better than the managers
do
socialists want to flatten labor
hierarchies as much as possible and
bring real democracy to the workplace
workers should be able to elect their
managers and should make up at least
part of every company's board
we believe that the rights of all humans
are universal that we're all created
equal
no matter the color of our skin or where
we come from or our sex
gender ability or who we love no one
should be considered a second-class
citizen because of some immutable
characteristic
we believe everyone should truly get a
fair shake and there's nothing more
american than that
okay that's all well and good but don't
socialists want to take away people's
freedom and make us all poor
on the contrary we believe that
capitalism stands in the way of real
freedom
and we want to fix that are you really
free to live your life if you spend 10
or 12 hours a day working for someone
else
if you don't have health insurance
because your employer won't provide it
and it's too expensive on the free
market
are you really free to buy the medicine
you need are you really free to buy a
home if you're barely able to make rent
sure capitalism allows for the
possibility of such things
but you're not really free to achieve
them if the very system is hell-bent on
making them impossible to reach
socialism addresses all of these
concerns in a more humane
post-capitalist society
all workers would make a fair wage and
they would have control over many of the
day-to-day operations of their
workplaces
their lives would be materially better
because they'd make more money
feel like their work is more meaningful
and work more reasonable hours when
profit is not the sole driving factor
healthcare would be free and universal
so you wouldn't have to worry about
getting sick and going bankrupt trying
to pay your medical bills
modest homes could be guaranteed to each
family with the option of buying a
larger one if that's what's important to
you
the point is socialism aims to expand
your freedom not take it away
the people who claim socialism is trying
to steal your freedom are the same
people who have a vested interest in
keeping capitalism around
they'd have to pay their workers a fair
wage and that's not in keeping with the
capitalist goal of ever increasing
profits
now let's address the socialism makes
everyone poor fallacy
there's an expression on the left that
encapsulates the vision of wealth
redistribution
from each according to their ability to
each according to their need
in short those with more money
contribute more and those with less
money contribute less
all for the benefit of everyone in
society some people may not like this
idea at first but think of it like this
have you ever been to a potluck if not
it's a kind of communal meal where
everyone contributes something
someone with more disposable income
might provide steaks or seafood
someone who's a good baker might bring
delicious homemade pies if you don't
have the means to bring anything big or
expensive
you could always contribute a bag of
chips some soda or paper plates
these are all things that people can use
and will appreciate the end result of
everyone contributing something is a
meal that is greater than any one person
could have enjoyed themselves
it's fun it's communal and it makes
everyone feel like a part of something
great
this is the vision of wealth
redistribution in a nutshell
now apply this to society at large
beautiful public parks for everyone to
enjoy
high-speed public transportation that
will make commuting much less stressful
and cut pollution
libraries where anyone can borrow books
or movies or take classes
state-of-the-art schools for our
children this is a vision of the world
that is possible
if we can move beyond the toxic greed of
capitalism does this all sound like you
do you believe we need to address the
material concerns of average people
do you believe that everyone is created
equal that we should expand democracy
that healthcare and a decent standard of
living are basic human rights
that we should work together to build a
better tomorrow for everyone
that we need to move beyond capitalism
to ensure a livable future
if this does sound like you
congratulations you're a socialist
now there are plenty of different
perspectives within the left some
advocate for a classless moneyless
society
some for a form of market socialism some
for a near-complete flattening of
hierarchies
but what they all have in common is a
belief in equality dignity and the value
of human life
and that's something we should all agree
upon so come on in
we'll be glad to have you
this topic is so important to me i try
my best to understand and learn as much
as i can so i can share with others
and one way i like to do that is by
listening to audiobooks i travel a lot
for work so i have plenty of time to sit
on planes and listen to fascinating
audiobooks on audible
one great one that i recently listened
to is socialism seriously
by danny ketch it's a great short listen
about five hours long and it's a
fantastic primer for those new to the
left
it's funny easy to understand and it
really does a great job of painting a
picture of what life could be like if we
just decided it was time to move beyond
capitalism
now is a great time to get into audible
because for a limited time you can take
advantage of their holiday offer and get
your first 6 months of audible plus for
just 4.95 a month
if you like to learn as much as i do
less than 5 bucks a month is an
incredible deal
audible plus is a little different than
what you're probably used to instead of
getting one free audiobook per month
with audible plus you get access to the
entire library of thousands of
audiobooks podcasts and originals
included in the plus catalog
and you can listen to as much as you
want have 10 books you've been meaning
to read
sign up for audible plus and listen to
all of them for just 4.95
i don't think i can accurately convey
how much i love audible i struggle to
sit down and read a book
but with audible i can get through all
the titles i've wanted to all while
running errands or commuting or
traveling for work
it's completely changed how i learn if
you enjoyed this week's video i highly
highly recommend you check out socialism
seriously on audible it's a fantastic
listen
if you want to help support my channel
so i can produce more content like this
visit audible.com second thought or text
second thought one word to 500 500.
sign up today and get your first six
months of audible plus for just 4.95 a
month
it really does help support me and my
channel follow the link below or text
second thought to 500-500
[Music]
you